ahora que ya vimos las curvas de
titulación también conocidas como curvas
de valoración
veamos cómo podemos usar un indicador ha
sido base para encontrar el punto de
equipales ya de la titulación un
indicador cambia de color en un rango
específico de ph por ejemplo el rojo de
metilo es un indicador que cambia de
rojo a amarillo en un rango de ph de 4.4
a 6.2 podemos decir que es un rango de
aproximadamente 4 a 6 por otro lado el
azul de promo timol es un indicador que
cambia de amarillo a azul en un rango de
6 a 7 puntos 6 podemos decir que es
aproximadamente de 6 a 8 y la fenol
talina es un indicador que pasa de ser
transparente a color rosa en un rango de
ph de 8.2 a 10
podemos decir que este aproximadamente 8
a 10
entonces analicemos nuestras curvas de
titulación y veamos qué indicador ha
sido base podemos usar empecemos con la
curva de arriba esta fue la curva de
valoración para la titulación de un
ácido fuerte con una base fuerte en el
punto de equivalencia el ph es igual a 7
aquí tenemos el ph de 7 y este fue
nuestro punto de equivalencia que para
el ejemplo que hicimos lo alcanzamos al
agregar 20 mililitros de la base fuerte
entonces al hacer una titulación de un
ácido fuerte con una base fuerte el ph
es igual a 7 en el punto de equivalencia
veamos que indicador ha sido base
podríamos usar para esta titulación
necesitamos un indicador que cambie de
color en un rango cercano al punto de
equivalencia por ejemplo el azul de
bromo timol cambia de 6 a 8 en un ph de
6 el bromo timol es de color amarillo en
este punto y después cambia a color azul
y tal vez antes de que sea totalmente
azul alcanzamos a ver un poco de verde
entonces como ocurre un cambio de color
en este rango el azul de bromo timol
sería un buen indicador ha sido base
para esta titulación y cuando el color
azul persiste significa que hemos
alcanzado el punto final de la
titulación así que esta es una buena
aproximación al punto de equivalencia
observen que en el caso de un ácido
fuerte y una base fuerte tenemos una
curva de titulación muy empinada que va
desde el ph 4 hasta 10 así que también
podríamos usar los otros dos indicadores
podríamos usar rojo de metilo porque
cambia de rojo a amarillo en un rango de
ph de 4 a 6 y eso también nos da una
buena aproximación del punto de
equivalencia o podríamos usar fenol
talina que cambia a color rosa en un
rango de ph de 8 a 10 entonces al tener
una curva de titulación como ésta
podemos usar cualquiera de los tres
indicadores ácido base para encontrar el
punto de equipaje de la titulación ahora
analicemos la curva de valoración para
la titulación de un ácido c débil con
una base fuerte en este ejemplo
empezamos con ácido acético
y agregamos una base fuerte hidróxido de
sodio y obtuvimos que el ph en el punto
de equivalencia es mayor a 7 en nuestro
ejemplo fue muy cercano a 9 y usamos 200
mililitros de la base fuerte para
alcanzar el punto de equivalencia
entonces el ph es mayor a 7 en el punto
de equivalencia porque en este tipo de
titulaciones neutralizamos un ácido
débil y nos queda la base con jugada de
ese ácido que al reaccionar con agua
aumenta la concentración de iones
hidróxido en la solución
por eso el ph es mayor a 7 los invito a
ver el vídeo sobre esa titulación para
que vean cómo se hizo el cálculo
entonces para la titulación de un ácido
débil con una base fuerte el ph es mayor
a 7 por lo tanto necesitamos elegir un
indicador ha sido base que cambia de
color
en un rango mayor a 7 en este caso la fe
no está ley na funcionaría muy bien
porque cambia en un rango de 8 a 10 así
que en este rango observaríamos un
cambio de color de transparente arroz y
de tendríamos nuestra titulación en ese
punto que es una buena aproximación del
punto de equivalencia ahora observen que
no podríamos usar rojo de metilo porque
este indicador cambia en un rango de 4 a
6 que en nuestra curva de titulación
empezaríamos aquí en color rojo y
después el indicador cambiaría a color
amarillo en algún punto por aquí habría
un cambio de color en esta zona y
perderíamos el punto de equivalencia
finalmente veamos la curva de valoración
para la titulación de una base débil con
un ácido fuerte empezamos con una base
débil y por eso la curva inicia con un
ph
básico antes de agregar el ácido y en
este caso el ph en el punto de
equivalencia es menor a 7 porque si
hacemos reaccionar toda la base débil
con un ácido fuerte pro tomamos la base
débil en nuestro ejemplo usamos nh3
amoniaco que al protón arlo nos queda
nh 4 más es un ácido así que en el punto
de equivalencia tenemos amonio que puede
donar un protón al agua aumentando así
la concentración de iones sidronio en la
solución
por eso el ph es menor a 7 en el punto
de equivalencia y en nuestro ejemplo
obtuvimos un ph ligeramente arriba de 5
este es el punto de equivalencia ahora
veamos que indicador ha sido base
podemos usar para este caso necesitamos
usar un indicador que cambie de color en
un rango de ph
es menor a 7 así que el rojo de metilo
es una buena opción el rojo de metilo
será de color amarillo con un ph de 6
pero cambiará a color rojo y este sería
el punto final de nuestra titulación
justo en donde observamos el cambio de
color del indicador así que esta es una
buena forma de encontrar el punto de
equipaje pero observen que no es buena
opción usar fenol talina para este caso
porque la fenol talina cambiará de color
en esta zona de arriba con un ph de 10
será de color rosa y después cambiará y
será transparente en esta zona así que
perderíamos el punto de equivalencia
por eso la fen ortale inah no funciona
para esta titulación pero el rojo de
metilo es la mejor opción